now let's meet the cast of Dancing with
the Stars my name is miles Brown aka
baby Boogaloo I play Jack Johnson on the
show black I have no cookies my name is
Ariana green black and I'm most known
for a little more and adventures and
infinity did you do it yes did it cost
Thompson and most people know me as
funny baby I really didn't like the idea
of being grounded and I didn't like it
more when I knew it was and I am the
youngest boy to ever compete at the
Scripps National Science I and V I se a
tee in the skate that is correct my
hobbies
[Music]
and do
Fighting's karate kicks it dance and
scene I have a lot my name is Marla
Morris and my dad is Stevie Wonder
[Music]
learning Sophia fitness
up in the legend Scottie Pippen hey guys
it tells me I'm starting YouTube channel
and I'm going to be talking about my
daily routine makeup tutorials and
pranks let's get on the video I am
Hudson West I play cheek wiper own
General Hospital which makes me your
biological uncle no that's not right you
made a mistake
I am Mackenzie Ziegler and I am a singer
my sister Maddie is also a performer so
I want to follow in her footsteps
[Music]
go on breathe
my name is Tripp I'm from Alaska my
mom's worse than my grandma Sarah Palin
he was like the youngest one on the show
one of the youngest I think and I said
Tripp have fun make friends you know
learn some manners with girls you know
how are you gonna you're gonna learn how
to dance just have fun make friends and
that's what he did he had such an
amazing time and their memories that
he's gonna have forever
he's in corkmaster 15 here hey guys it's
shears Madison today we're going to be
making spinach and artichoke filled with
garlic bread hi I'm Jason Adama I play
me vibration on Astro raise and it's
only now that I'm a TV star
it's really known here with more
experience
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]